serious new danger is threatening
people's health near Hawaii's lava flows
rivers of slow-moving molten rock
reached the ocean over the weekend the
reaction is creating a toxic corrosive
gas that can spread for miles that comes
as the eruptions caused their first
major injury
mark Strassmann is in Kapoho Hawaii near
an active fissure mark good morning good
morning well take a look
that's molten lava doing an angry dance
behind me how hot is it that lava is
around 2,000 degrees geologists here
call this fissure 20 and the lava that
is poured relentlessly from it for days
needs someplace to go
we found the endpoint this is what
officials here have warned about for
days Swift moving molten rock from the
Kilauea volcano that is finally run out
of room you're looking at a river of
lava spill into the Pacific Ocean it
came from fissure 21 of the most dynamic
racing as quickly as a half mile an hour
before ending here at the water's edge
the resulting Steam Cloud is called
Lay's a mix of lava and haze it's laced
with hydrochloric acid which is toxic
and burns uncontacted officials warned
the cloud could extend 15 miles
meanwhile fish's few more lava into
neighborhoods like Leilani estates where
some are still defined evacuation orders
I have no fear for not getting out if
something catastrophic could happen but
I don't believe anything catastrophic
will happen
looks pretty catastrophic behind you
well but I'm saying though right now you
know it wouldn't blow up and cause us to
be running down the road it would be
real slow
but another hold out in leilani Estates
was hit by lava spatter that shattered
his shin these aerials show the scope of
molten rock pouring from active fissures
one flow crossed highway 137 over the
weekend a lava mountain 30 feet high
geologist carolyn part jetta
i think we're moving into phase 2 and
that's where we're gonna see increased
activity potentially higher fountains
more lava flows much more dynamic
situation than before because of the
dangers of flying lava we're trying to
keep a safe distance from this fissure
about a half mile just as we did in our
boat trip to watch the lava pour into
the Pacific there two officials say that
lava shows no sign of slowing Gale all
right thank you mark Strassmann
reporting from Hawaii